returns a snippet of current audio of
some length correct so but it returns
that from the moment you ask it to the
moment it thinks it's finished recording
exactly okay
Network packet recording ok so network
packet recording takes a certain amount
of time current audio I have to say this
looks wrong to me I mean I would have
thought the one argument formed be a
duration because the source hasn't the
source been set externally somehow sorry
we could we could set up we could accept
duration that's the first argument as
well so either of those two could be
optional right I mean if you if you want
to look at an existing function right
there's current image right the current
image is just a one-shot deal no it's
not you can ask for some number of
images what did I just find what just
happened here am I going crazy or does
it know stick a ref in front of it
it's a filed bug in the prototype build
okay oh I'm in the prototype build here
or maybe it's also in you know master
builds but there Knightley's but it got
filed this morning who wants to be the
new model for current image somebody in
the image processing team sure I mean
next a conference will get take care
what's that sure
naigus better at the tech conference we
can have people try addition for the
next documentation image right um okay
in any case okay so this returns and
sequential images as a list so how long
a part of those images depends on the
frame rate that's that is specified in
the device properties so in other words
it's at the frame rate it's and things
that the frame rate
mm-hmm um is that one go ahead the one
minor difference here
I don't know how network packet
recording works you know that when we
start the camera the camera gets going
for two minutes before it shuts down or
before the timeout is over and if you
ask for Karen image bracket bracket you
get one sample back then a few seconds
later you ask for Karen image of ten if
the buffer already has the ten frames we
return 10 latest frames from from the
buffer that we can as well change but
you know I mean that's not even
documented is it so I mean how does that
relate to the whole device read and
device read latest and so on what is
happening here I gotta use them on
documentation search is broken so you
need to put in the rest okay all right
okay you still ready said that twice let
me see if I can actually remember it
this time okay device read latest right
I'm using the current version great okay
so what does this do
that's the most recently collected items
- yeah
that's equivalent to Karen imagine if
the if the cameras already started
otherwise if the cameras previously
started previously yes otherwise we'll
have to start the camera
fill in the buffer get to the end image
and then return the list okay but don't
we have a device read buffer which reads
the complete contents of the buffer on a
device right which is what you're saying
if if the thing had if you had been
collecting things for whatever random
reason in the camera this would read
that stuff and him to the buffer correct
I haven't tested it but yes that seems
like a sensible behavior okay but I
don't think you know we got to decide
are we looking at the past or the future
with these functions mm-hmm I mean we
can guarantee to look at the future the
past you know we might not have um humph
okay so what we've got here is we've got
current image which mist which looks
either at past or future
we've got current audio conceptually of
a duration current image notices not of
a duration it's of a frame count mm-hmm
right we could still accept the duration
a time quantity there as well which
probably makes sense for something like
Karen video down the road or something
sorry sorry I wasn't I lost what did you
say I'm saying we can accept a time
quantity as well instead of an or in
addition to n so that as well could be
yeah I do right sure current Network
packet capture or something
well no image capture is the analog of
current network packets I suppose right
and so I will my argument is twofold
one is we have some precedent with
current image and you know we were stare
was already thought to extend that to
current audio current video and so forth
the other is I don't know that I could
tell you the difference between network
attack could capture and network packet
recording and you I could but it's not
like I could remember what have we done
with the thing that was going to be
called audio recording so audio
recording is or audio record is a
different thing because that is says to
start record right now right it's like
there's an audio record and that
complementary audio pause and they
presume an audio stop right those are
like the buttons that's like the record
button on the string
actions on the stream yes sorry sorry
sorry
I've got distracted for a second could
you could you say that again so we have
an audio stream object which which could
be linked to a speaker a playback device
or a recording device okay and then we
have controls functions that control the
stream like audio play audio pause I
mean you could imagine if you really
want to get obsessive about it you could
have a network packet stream or is that
not the case and it's a little bit
difficult to do it in a dream I guess
you could in theory it seems weird but
but because in the case of a video
stream it's pretty obvious what it means
to playback it's pretty obvious what it
means to record it all right but bottom
line since I kind of agree with you a
type that the current network packets
make sense in you know and an analogy to
these things okay and I suppose we could
do the thing of having n or time here
and then we could do I mean current
audio I don't even know what on earth
that I mean there we've just got to have
a time I don't really think n makes well
I mean there is the sample rate of
course right there's some number of
samples mm-hmm so I suppose we could do
the same thing there now I have to say
in terms of device doesn't current image
have a device a way of changing the
device it does doesn't it but isn't that
isn't that current imaging device or
something imaging device not current
okay okay so but that's that's part of
the options so I don't understand why
that's not what you're doing for current
audio so audio audio input device audio
yeah okay sure we can do that I would
think so because then we can have a
dollar because you know there we have
dollar imaging device we can have a
dollar audio device because most of the
time you're just going to want to set it
for a given session right okay all right
I'm good
so this network packet trace also seems
quite sensible this was a ridiculous
name here yes there was a meeting in
which it was already renamed which is
what's in okay all right fine all right
we're good okay are you ready for the
next item
yep who is only relevant for this first
item can leave if they want anybody
who's needed for what the heck is this
attire you want me for a dollar username
then let's get let's talk about this one
because I'm really curious what this one
is and then we'll skip to that one and
let Charlie go after that okay um so
open terminal and execute that how
horrified am I going to be I think
you'll be pleased okay that's always a
change it's not pointing at a recent
build you need to you need a newer build
I have a version of that maybe somebody
has to ask well Julie what it is does
anybody remember what the eye I have I
always have a new version what is it
called um Garrett do you know what the
new version is here I'm not sure what
it's called there was also in I think it
might have been today's Wolfram script
so I don't know if that'll help us
either
all right if you take that picture at I
know all I see is a big mountainside
picture okay go ahead
so that is a cat oh that's a wonderful
cat yes how impressive the criminal can
render it yes so I've actually tested it
I've been testing it across different
terminals so the maximum can do it a
Linux terminal can do it
the Windows terminal can't do it but if
you use something like cygwin then it
can do it so and they're still bugs here
so for example if I if I do Wolfram
script and I tried to paste in this
thing into terminal I'm hitting command
V and nothing's happening birth up for
us or is that I mean that's a book for
us because why because if I turn off
some input history and I've never seen
that option before Garrett what is that
option it's an option it's an option to
the kernel but it's an undocumented
option to go from script isn't it okay
yep
yes which disables the the arrow keys in
history so I go right so clearly there's
an option yeah it's a good option and by
the way we should but we should document
it and so there's clearly some bug yep
yeah but so the main takeaway here is
that that non plane 0 unicode is
starting to work correct you know if it
works on the command line if I pass it
through the shell command line I presume
that's what you know
what you doing here other words if you
resolve the front character code there
and if the - code is of the emoticon
right so yeah so if if you yes so if I
do something like echo the cat and pipe
that the Wolfram script then it will it
will incorrectly interpret the cat okay
good okay all right so other than being
happy what what is the next step right
so so alright so we have utf-8
alright so okay so there are a few
different steps one is the cloud and
I've talked to June and she's going to
be testing we have no idea what will
happen when you try connecting this
kernel to the cloud so that's just an
experiment that needs to happen and let
me just understand that so the issue is
whether the cloud notebook editor can
pass non-playing zero unicode is that
correct correct okay another question is
whether the weather API is whether the
plumbing through Tomcat of the api's and
so on will work right which i think a -
and even a third question is whether
when you have an incident form that's
been put up by the cloud whether it's
smart fields will correctly pass this
stuff right and I I don't know about the
internals of any of those things - even
hazard a guess yeah I'm gonna guess that
they're gonna be some bumps um do we
know whether like an interpreter does
interpreter eat these things okay or not
[Music]
if it's a semantic interpreter then it's
gonna be then the Alpha server is gonna
be an obstacle right that's right well
you're gonna have to put some protection
in for that probably for the time being
so we don't end up messing something up
horribly
yeah I can think about that right um
right so the front and the master front
end currently doesn't support these
characters at all if you
I understand but that's presumably
coming right so in the prototype build
John has started fixing some things but
that's at most 25% done so it will work
in a few places and be horribly broken
in other places all right but but so who
has okay who is project managing the
process of getting this even inventory
and where this has to work and then
making sure it does in each case who has
the list of where it's supposed to work
whose project managing here okay well
between you and parth
I think you should figure out who who is
making that master list okay and I think
we already gave you a bunch of places I
mean I'll give you another place which
is reading these from files I have no
idea how that possibly works so right so
if you import the file as utf-8 yeah I
understand but okay so what you're
saying is okay so let me let me just
list you a few other ones service
connections like for example reading off
a Twitter feed no idea how that's
encoded I have no reason to think that
it's utf-8 so anybody have any idea here
a lot of it wouldn't surprise me if like
say Twitter was standardized you know
hard enough it they forced them encoding
like okay let me give you some other
just totally random other weird cases
like exif data for images no idea how
that's encoded shoddy any idea okay well
I think that the main main thing is any
place where we're getting something from
the outside world that is string like we
have to worry about it and my guess is
there will be a bug tail that will last
for a while with these things right I
mean I think you know here's another one
that's interesting story is rasterized I
don't even know what fonts you know when
rasterized rasterizes it's presumably
using system fonts and presumably on the
popular platforms there are standardized
fonts for most of the you know most of
the emoji but I don't know under Linux
are there emoji fonts yes other how does
okay
this we're getting off track here but
I'm gonna ask a question so you know we
were involved in the original unicode
1.0 standard back in the 1990's and we
even added some of her own characters to
it except we didn't even try for the
wolf um but in the modern times you know
there's a there's a progressive advance
of emoji how does that work timewise
does anybody know I mean so people say
we want an emoji that's a picture of a
strawberry or something and then somehow
the Unicode consortium agrees that
they're going to have an emoji of a
strawberry but then how does that work
in terms of the release of that and they
release the fonts that supported and so
on I think once a year or so Unicode
updates a version send you know updates
the standard so that the officially
published a standard saying you know new
and this version code point one two
three four five six is my favorite
strawberry and you know did the glyph
should look vaguely like this yep and
then you know the OS vendors will then
subsequently issue an update saying we
now support Unicode blah and that that
will include fonts which you know I
understand I don't think that could be
completely correct but
we shouldn't speculate because some
people were actually know the answer
this but I think hasn't Apple sort of
excited people by introducing you know
various kinds of politically correct
emoji and so on and and how did they do
that is that in private Unicode space
and if it isn't private you know they go
through the consortium for everything as
far as I know that they propose very not
fine I mean then the other possibility
is that we need we might need to go look
at some you know if we had to curate
what the structure of some stuff and
private Unicode spaces then so be it
another question is given that we're
expanding our Unicode coverage does
anybody know again this is the wrong
group of people but this is something
for Sushma to chase down and maybe we
need a separate meeting about this non
planes there are Unicode stuff I mean
you know fonts fork Renea form and God
knows what else right do we have that
stuff is there do it does anybody know
because for example for rasterization
it's simply not going to work unless
somewhere we have that font it's also
not obvious that in some of these very
exotic fonts and given that we have
cloud connectivity that we shouldn't
just go to the cloud to get some
rasterization done if we're sufficiently
out of fonts on a local machine
well most I mean anything that's not
explicitly in one of our table we will
use system fonts for yeah and system
fonts for all Unicode code point so that
there's system fonts for an awful lot of
them so if I were to pick I mean if I
were to simply say I mean right now this
is not in this is not far out in Unicode
space but if I were to just say no
definitely don't mean random real and I
would say from character code here
okay so I'm getting a hit rate I'm
getting a failed glyph rate see that
failed bluff rate right how many of
those they all exist everything in your
code has been filled in let's find out
hold on one second it's just just for
the hell of it what's the Shamrock I
have no idea
amrok is the fact that it's green is
totally remarkable okay let's let's look
at that I okay that guy there okay let's
say two character code of that okay
that's
oh is that in private Unicode space I
think it's try pasting it into like
TextEdit or something okay oops
fine okay that is not in private Unicode
space
so let's find out so you say I should
paste this into TextEdit what's this
that I've got I've got a shell here if I
paste it into that what the heck is that
doing blah well I think I just don't
have that font right well the question
is what is a nine five eight right I
mean if that's for example in the
surrogate pair spaced and there's no
character right not not every point code
point is actually a useful character
okay a point zero is null that's not
exactly the most interesting glyph in
the world okay so if I all scoff now for
what character that is it says what the
heck is we Jiang and look we can't even
render it here
I thought we had bitmaps of everything
what is this oh you know what it may
what is this well okay a separate topic
but we got to go chase down what what
what's going on there is a non spacing
combining mark which just doesn't have a
visual form right okay but then then
we're displaying it wrong here because
it doesn't have a visual form it's not
like we should be displaying it as a
question mark we should just be
displaying it well but you'll notice
that you know your terminal did the same
rendering that this is that was the one
I was just looking at okay great I mean
so so I don't think it's us drawing that
question mark I think it's data wise
font system saying I have no font with
this okay what is this we say the visual
form is a PI or PI light character and
Wolfram Alpha and yet here we're saying
we don't know what it is it is notable
that we don't have any oh it's a private
use area oh gosh okay who knows um I'll
try just one more right so right so
there are two two levels of support
there there is being able to handle the
code point and you know not corrupt the
code point and and that's the level
where you know say the front end is
going to strive to be I can accept this
code point and I will not turn it on and
I will display something that vaguely
resembles that
well then there's a second level which
is to semantically understand the code
point if there is something to
semantically understand and you know
right cuz there are character code
points which are say start rendering
from right to left until you hit and you
know my opposite we understand and so
you know so that means we you know the
front then first of all we need to the
underside what that even means in the
front end and then the front end would
need to learn all these characters and
what to do with them there's things like
is it a lesser like character those
kinds of things which are gonna have to
be covered right let's let a cube true
or false for an emoji right and okay my
by the way why is the shamrock green
that seems extremely exotic okay well in
any case all right look the main thing
for sushma and path is to go inventory
what all the places these strings can
get in and out are and then I think
separately we need to find out what's
happened what's going on with fonts yeah
we yes yes I mean there are a few other
things so for example right now we have
[Music]
you know character in the binary right
we have character 8 and character 16
Mobley we should also have a character
32 I think so and to me is that maybe
something Garrett could work on Oh
Garrett somebody associated with Garrett
could work on this Garrett's still here
or did we say go out away no I'm sorry
hey possibly it's so that a dave lebryk
thing I'm wondering
how much work it needs to be changed I
would think it's pretty straightforward
yeah I mean I don't know whether there's
any end in this nonsense going on with
it okay 16 and just right let's move on
I think well I think we it's clear what
we do here the thing we're gonna need
for a meeting specifically about plane
one Unicode which I don't necessarily
have to be in is that inventory of where
it goes in where it comes out yes then
also I mean other things we're missing
are you know utf-16 do we want
big-endian little-endian versions there
I've we don't have utf-32 need those
things but how are you gonna
parameterize the big and little endian
versions with different names well you
could either I mean we could either yeah
give little different names right so we
could we could have a big-endian we
could have a utf-16 which was just
playing you know follow the current
investable to me and the question is do
we also want separate names which force
the nd in this or I think so but what
have we done with endianness and other
four other data types for other raw data
types what are we doing with endianness
in the language client libraries do you
know that's a Dorian thing yeah I
alright this is not for this meeting
let's go track down it's a good question
but let's track it down and then talk
about it once it's tracked down okay um
okay should we move on we're gonna do
the last item here this user dollar
username yeah I mean this is this is in
the you know my claim about language is
words always get smooshed and what we
currently have is dollar username with a
capital n right I have a last couple of
hours should I do it
let me see like my commitment sprout
probably you should update okay okay so
what am I gonna see here right so so the
the problem is that right we can't have
a page four dollar username and four
dollar username because you can't have
two different pages which differ only in
case on the casement sensitive file
system like you have on your Mac so my
suggestion so I could in the future I
mean I'll I'll need to go and like
rewrite the whole page with the correct
case and everything but what I put on
the page was a tentative note which says
something like for compatibility with
you know earlier versions of the Wolfram
language Fowler username can also be is
also available in the variable dollar
user capital name
that's fine where you're going to put it
in the in the details section exactly I
think that's fine yeah so it's kind of
ugly and I don't it's not the best thing
but language evolves and I think we have
to take account of that we also need to
make sure the autocomplete er
understands this properly okay and
arguably the autocomplete if you say
this the auto computer should still be
trying to complete it as this one if it
can that's if that's a you know a major
issue then handle it differently yeah I
mean I think the moment we update the
documentation so that the documented
forum installer user lowercase name then
that will automatically bump it higher
okay fine
all right let's assume that it's gonna
be okay I'm sorry one question do those
things represent the same thing thank
you
yeah because I would say user name is
kind of mine name or the other one with
lowercase this is the user name I used
logging that's right this one is the
computer idle username right and we
don't need the other one well we do but
the other one for how many years 22 but
do we need to store the then name the
actual full name of the user we do but
that's a completely different variable
oh I see so so what's going to be the
name of the of this other one
it's storing the ending full name I've
forgotten but but there is another maybe
we already have it um it's odd that we
don't already have that there um and by
the way this this should point to
authentication dialog and various other
kinds of things
the stoller username symbol um I don't
remember what it is called okay yeah
it's something like dollar personal name
I see okay yeah I see here we're saying
username password lowercase M alright
anyway okay it sounds okay to me alright
um that was the thing that shadi was
needed for I don't quite know why shot
he was involved in that at all but
because the motivation for this okay
fine all right so should we move on to
the next thing shot if you can leave if
she wants to but is welcome to stay um
okay we have many kinds of missing with
different string arguments so this is
some email that you apparently sent to
Sushma and we I mean I presume you're
talking about some sort of print form
for mr. Graham yes but we were not able
to decipher what it is you're asking for
here okay so what I'm asking for for
example in data set for its sins it is
displaying missing as just a - that's
the traditional form of missing oh is
that right yes okay um okay
so I guess I'm asking for the standard
form whether we think that there is a
better more blob-like
thing because I mean something like this
missing key absent seems kind of ugly
and it seems kind of like I mean I'm
wondering
this would better be some more graphical
form some so-called aside blob I mean it
would be more obvious if you saw it you
know if you have something where there's
a BC and then missing a blah blah blah
this just looks like something ugly
whereas I don't see why we can't have
some typeset form for this okay you
don't have any particular as to what
that form should be well not yet
I mean you know and the other question
is where the key absent should be D
camels and things and whether it should
be something that it's more like you
know because I mean if we were going
entity like which wouldn't be a totally
crazy pattern oh boy this is a version
that doesn't support this probably help
this is probably gonna crash in some
horrible way but anyway we all know that
that will be display as New York City
with camel with with them great um that
you know that will display in some
reasonable way but yet underneath it's
got camel stuff right so I'm suggesting
that and I don't know what color it
should be maybe it's a ghost color or
something some kind of grey ghost color
or some such other thing yeah wasn't
sure if it was gonna be a grayish or
like an orangish or reddish or something
I see I think it should be I think
missing is more of a yeah I mean so if
we have that but the input form there is
something much more like you know the
missing camel case thing well what kind
of motif what's the right motif maybe
the right motif is and now I'm getting a
little crazy that some kind of what
about a well we need the design folk
here if we're really going to do this
I'm you know what about a dotted red
line around a gray thing there there's
my there's my crazy compromise design
that makes sense although we use missing
in much more than just entities I'm not
talking about
and nothing to do with entities I'm just
saying as a pattern here for what it
might look like I'm suggesting gray with
a dotted red border he's just looking at
the rounded directive entity a think yes
okay that's my suggestion let's take it
to design for further discussion there
okay
okay what is this okay so this is
something that was apparently started at
some some years ago and then sort of
abandoned it has if you open if you just
say we have people who think you know
about this thing if Lou is still here
yes I know about it so it was intended
to be the the fourth it was intended to
do for grid what plot and list plot did
for graphics okay so if you remove the
list then that would work so that's a
different that's a different function
that's experimental eight
okay and why did we never finish this I
don't know that right I don't remember I
think part of it is that specifying
headings got quite complicated it's
probably less complicated in the world
of associations possibly I mean because
I think we were doing this before
associations were thing right and so you
know we get these various suggestions of
you know cleaning up dataset for example
I'm not going to be anywhere near the
gravest attempt to clean up that mess
but the for added support for
Association directly to column for
instance has been a has been a
suggestion in the past right so my my
idea is that this is sort of I mean
forget the names but that the these
functions are sort of the right level of
abstraction
right you can give it a list or a matrix
or an association and it will have a you
know theme a whatever you know not know
table theme yep and so I you know by the
way I do think we might consider just
generalizing plot theme and all the
other theme II things to just a theme
option
I think that that is going to be
possible I mean maybe we should look at
that see whether there's any obstruction
to doing that
um okay there was a separate branch but
in here I mean it does look like it
should be finished and and you know the
whole headings thing could be done with
associations so we don't have to get
hairy I mean the old table formed thing
had a bunch of headings mechanisms that
I consider to be you know that I mean
this is the shocking thing those through
design like 31 years ago the fact that
they're not really embarrassing is
wonderful but they're definitely not as
modern as they could be um they're not
terrible but they it seems like in
modern times with associations we should
just use those to define the headings
because that way the headings are fully
computable that make sense everybody I
mean I don't I don't disagree that we
should support associations and you
support you know automatically you know
inferring headings but I don't know that
you know I don't think that's you know I
don't think that replaces the need for
manually specifying headings I can
conceive of associ you know fair enough
fair enough no I agreed that one might
want an overlay of some other heading
right so what's the question here the
question here is all we gonna jump in
and try and finish these basically there
are two questions basically are you
signing off on the idea of trying to
finish these functions who would do the
work is it Lou or somebody else would be
either me or eat I for the low level
stuff and then for the theme support we
might want to involve only Tim or
somebody okay but how does this relate
to the work that's being done on data
set can we somehow combine these efforts
I don't know if there's anyone in this
meeting that can answer that so it would
be closest to that we're here yeah I'm
here
do you have an opinion about that if
you've been paying attention to this
questions all the Revere's work on say
via however he says it is so yes I'm
sorry I've been following the discussion
so what I would say is that so far he is
still mainly fixing backs not so much
extending into new functionality no I
understand but for example here if we
said let's tabulate will be expected to
page probably yes just what I'm saying
and by the time we're paging this that's
very close to some of the data set
functionality see is that what we want
I'm not sure that's what we really want
or at least it's not obviously that's
something we want by default not obvious
I agree it's not obvious there might be
something that we I mean do we expect
okay so the point of let's tabulate is
it is a smarter column so to speak is
that right right the point of tabulate
this tabulate is that it is a smarter
column or grid or table form depending
on what input or one isn't but you give
it
okay and if I do 3-way what's it gonna
do probably nothing okay that's not
totally stupid yeah
booming so so this thing okay yeah I
agree that this is perfectly a perfectly
reasonable thing um list a Beulah is a
bit of an odd name for that construct
because you know tabulate makes perfect
sense and it's clearly a useful function
although people are going to want to go
from the tabulated form and what happens
if I make a tabulated form and then I
say oh whoops I want to compute from it
what do they do that
compute with what aspects of it the
contents like I say this is wonderful
eating the headings that's correct right
so there would have to be some so there
are two possibilities one is there would
have to be some additional function that
would be wrapped around this that would
extract just the the core or the other
is that that this would immediately
evaluate to just the core right so this
output would not if you were to evaluate
this output as input no that that's too
fragile
that's way too fragile I mean you know
unfortunately one is slippery like you
know when it's quickly going down the
slippery slope of we've got a bunch of
background noise by the way of data set
right that you're gonna want something
just like data set here
this is what data said is doing it it's
formatting and then it is providing
something that has well defined you know
operations that can be done on it
right which is why I think the the list
tabulate form is the more interesting /
useful thing right because I can do the
tabulate for but I guess modulo headings
I guess it has some extra support for
nicely making headings but right I can
basically make the tabulate form by
wrapping list have you laid around the
table yes
although except for the headings right
[Music]
but so but I think sort of right you
know but I'm sorry but you see list
Kavya is a one-way output form is that
correct yes it is super grid right it's
as lucid at the beginning it is - it is
- grid and column as plot is to graphics
so it takes some input and generates you
know I got it I agree yeah okay that was
the original concept of this function
like ten years ago or something and
we're wouldn't be these like like an
equivalent of matrix form like another
form thing
which has the property that it is a
wrapper where the assignment of the
input line is to the is to the core of
the thing the assignment of the output
line rather is to the core is that the
point you're making I was thinking of
using it exactly like table reform no
negative form or matrix form right where
the actual content here if I ask for
percent I will get the inner thing right
yeah yeah I mean what hasn't been done
for one of those is to have options for
the display I mean also that only works
as options and what would happen so we
just say slash slash table form as the
kind of qualitative version of that for
the output descriptor
you
okay so even though there are options
there that out you know the label does
not record the options
right I mean right column and grid are
not forms they're not no because but if
you pick them up you know in other words
if I made that a grid then the percent
of that is the grid itself which is the
correct thing right and so I'm just
saying I'm you know generally speaking
people are confused by forms and given
that we're thinking of this more as as
you know I guess the question is are we
thinking of this as a replacement for
column and grade are we thinking of this
as a replacement to Table four
because if we're thinking of it as a
replacement for column and grid it
shouldn't be print form I don't forget
is a replacement for any of them I think
it's a I think if anything it is serving
the type of use the table form serves
but the point is that table form is a
very primitive creature compared to data
set
is both something with evaluation
semantics and display
and you know we're teaching people to
use data set and data set in a sense
does a lot of the functionality of let's
tabulate and will have its own themes
and so on so what are we gaining from
this tabulate
not be having all the baggage of that
and also that you know if you're if
you're presenting an interface and what
you want is really the grid you know a
grid like thing in your inner in your
pretty printing and not all of the
baggage okay the only reason we're
talking about baggage is because of
implementation no it's not just the
implementation I mean right if you want
something that you know basically just
looks like this and you know it doesn't
respond your ways to clicks and whatnot
which are fundamentally part of the data
set interface well okay the data center
phase insofar as it's weird that's a
mistake
well it's detector can you open the page
of capital D and go to the last neat
example yeah okay but I mean yeah I can
do that just a second this is okay so
your point is this yeah I mean you know
I'm I don't know I mean - go go - go -
Ashley that's can't imagine what I'm
gonna find that but whatever I hang is
the rough to running away okay and go to
where they last in need a neat example
okay yeah so they
is being able to construct something
like that without having to introduce so
much options so many options to my agree
but why isn't that working with data set
well because if the typesetting is not
going to be why these it's just the same
kind of idea no I mean there's no paging
there's no I understand that but I'm
saying that I don't think right and they
don't think data set is going today is
data set going to take four grand color
and color and yes it is that stuff it
will take for example having data set
having disbanding of pertinent colors I
support that and data set with an option
I mean if you want something which is a
display look if the main issue is line
printer paper which is what you're
basically saying there um okay so
there's our thing now let me say that I
say data set up that I may regret this
but let's just try it okay it's not
absolutely horrible
I mean right but that now you created
this thing that is you know some
semantics weird creature listen listen
listen
the fact that I can then go in and and
and sub look at sub parts of that is
great that's what I want
it's me any way you want but it's not
what people who want you know well they
don't have to do if they don't want it
but if they do wants it it's right there
look I think the main point is let's
let's zoom out for a second okay the
main point is tabulate and let's
tabulate have certain default formatting
which we like
right the fact that I I don't buy this
argument of dataset has baggage they
don't need I think that baggage is
perfectly useful I think that if you
don't need it don't use it I think the
main argument is that the defaults
formatting of tabulate list tabulate is
different from the default formatting of
data set okay and is thought to be
desirable so it's as if we need a
version of data set that can support
those different default formatting which
is not obviously crazy but I think the
way we need to think about this is at
the beginning to just imagine you know
supporting themes properly in data set
so that you know we can parameterize
getting you know the different
formatting that we want for tabulate and
then the question of whether we
ultimately have a top level function
that generates whose role is for example
tabulate could generate a data set with
the formatting by default set to be this
formatting that's thought to be more
appropriate for tabulation because you
know yes I understand but yeah but what
if you want to do something with those
grids and columns data set provides a
whole nice way of extracting pieces and
doing things to those you know elements
of the grid sure but if this is my final
product then this is don't care about
the fact that yes it is the case if you
took that data set and you wanted to
extract a piece of it
know kinds of ways to do it look
realistic you don't like the
implementation of data set and we all
agree and that's why data set is being
redone and you know well let me put it
this way data set this can be done in
much shorter time than we doing data set
and that's that's not an you know that's
not but but also
you know if if I'm if I'm trying to
create just sort of an interface I you
know data set has all sorts of
interactive behaviors which would you
could presumably switch off with three
different theme settings but look the
question there are two orthogonal
questions one is is the code base of
data set the right thing to be using to
do this and the answer in my opinion is
it should be if it isn't right now
that's because the code isn't good
enough because what it will then support
is all these different operations and
all these different kinds of things that
people will end up wanting for the
tabulated output that's point one point
two um is should there be a top-level
function called for example tabulate or
tabulation or something whose output is
a happens to be a data set but it is one
whose default themeing is something
closer to what we are currently
imagining for tabular and I think the
answer that is probably yes but it's a
much simpler story to explain because
the thing you get out is a data set you
can extract pieces of it you can select
pieces of it you can sort rows of it you
know columns of it all those kinds of
good things you know you can you can
sort by for example if you want to you
know if I wanted to sort this thing by I
don't know the length of the output for
example which I might want to do you
know I could in in you know I don't want
to have to go back to the list form you
know extract the list out of the output
um and and then and then start doing
things we have a beautiful mechanism for
doing that with data set which hopefully
we will support increasingly through
user assistance you know code completion
type things so anyway I think that the
takeaway from this as I see it is let's
understand what was done in terms of
formatting of this tabulate thing now I
think there was some other stuff done
what was done Lou what was done with the
table view mechanism that's yet a
different branch isn't it table view is
a complete
leave separate effort wonderful the
third such effort well but I mean it has
its own reason for being right which is
to give gridded input bring that up to
first-class citizenry right so in other
words it's a it's an it's a spreadsheet
like enterable data set like thing is
that correct I wouldn't have were data
set but yes it's it's without the word
data set yeah okay but then what does
table if you do what does it return it
can I run it does it exist it's like
it's like input field so I can say
experimental table view no it's not
experimental what is it
it's just table view really wow it's a
submarine function for the capital V if
we please cut the background noise thank
you
natan okay boy people who are watching
this live stream here's a function you
didn't know existed probably I didn't
know this was at this stage of
completion what happens if I enter a
string here wow that's cool okay what is
that is that a symbol is that a string
I believe the default so think of input
fields second argument that allows you
to specify what kinds of things you'd be
typing the default for table view is to
allow strings and numbers okay I don't
know why just happened to me I don't
know this maybe it's not documented yet
yes and it goes directly to write it I
mean that controlled there is a new
friend and that's a table view box if
you I think or Freight is that right
that's right yes if you if you
unformatted you'll see so what how does
this relate and we should wrap this
particular meeting but how does this
relate to any of the rest of what we're
talking about so what is this return if
this worked what would it return it
would return exactly what the out with
what this is showing exactly as if you
had evaluated an input field that you
typed into you would get back an input
field you know you evaluate an input
field of dynamic of X you get back an
input ISO but the setting of this is the
setting is the data and this would more
typically be table view of dynamic of M
that would you know formulate a dynamic
binding between what you're editing and
the state of some variable I say
and what's the relationship between this
and kind of spreadsheet and tray and
instant forms on the web and so on I
think the answer is you wouldn't need we
would need to finish table view box and
the the desktop front end and then the
curved front end would need to learn
about it as well but it's not the right
thing or is that I mean because there's
also you know that there's also all the
recurring element stuff in interpreter
right repeating elements sorry an
interpreter I'm talking about there the
thing that's used for example if you're
transporting stuff from Excel
you know it's using api's with repeating
element specifications actually isn't it
isn't it the thing that is the the array
interpreter thing I don't know what's
happened to this can I even kill it help
no well you're right that might be why
it isn't released or documented um that
it's not a good sign is it okay but what
I'm what I was talking about um what
version maybe I'm even running that the
prototype build here I'm running this
function in the prototype build which is
kind of crazy
oh yeah the the array element function
is it called now what is it called
anybody know what I'm talking about
the thing that's been introduced for a
rectangular repeating element yeah I
mean that that's what this thing that
you're showing is related to rectangular
repeating element because that's the
thing that in a form or the input to an
API specifies that you're bringing in a
box like this and I think there was an
intention to have some kind of pure web
javascript type from the
[Music]
yes some interface that's a pure web
interface that allows you to enter these
things as a way of in a form you know
bringing in rectangular repeating
element of fact I wonder what the status
of that is so maybe you could check into
that that will be a ricardo question if
i if i deploy a form with a rectangular
repeating element what does it actually
come out like I can try it I suppose
hold on one second
um let's see if I say X goes to a
repeating element rectangular repeating
element what the heck oh okay um okay
let's see what this does
fascinating the heck is that well I
don't know what this is gonna do let's
try this five four five six seven eight
whatever I am totally confused all right
what why don't you ask Ricardo what the
story with this is yes I mean what this
should do when you what that should do
is to bring up some kind of spreadsheet
like interface okay okay I thought we
had agreed that we were going to do that
with them using some kind of JavaScript
creature on the in the web and the web
interface here um but okay but this yeah
okay so this is a interface element like
thing Wow
well even as a graphic design level it
has to be made to agree with the other
things um someone on the live stream is
asking can you reference one cell from
another in that object well this is the
dynamic you know typical way one does
that
Thakur's is via variable values yeah and
dynamic so you're saying that dynamic
given that this thing was bound to X the
whole thing was bound to X X sub 4 comma
5 is is the appropriate element yes
that's correct
yes but the idea that for example one
would have a particular element you see
this is where the slippery slope starts
when starts sliding down the slippery
slope because then the next thing you're
going to want is that that element there
is represented by a formula in terms of
some of these other elements and I know
that's can be provided for in can it be
in the context of dynamic
I suppose it could it be I mean it seems
like it's a self-referential
we might we might run into referencing
problems
these are definitely things that we
would want to look into I mean this has
neat I says there's a reason we're not
we're not shipping this yeah yeah no I
understand I mean we could imagine some
some sort of I don't know computation
function or something that continuously
runs that that forces certain cells to
be constrained to be equal to some some
formula of in terms of other cells but
yeah I mean it's a it's a sort of a
different story
um fair enough okay great we've gone
over time here so we need to wrap up um
sounds good I think we got through our
agenda thanks guys and thank you to
people on livestream
thanks for the encouragement Tokio soon